はい それではよろしくお願いします
えっと 今日のテーマに入ります
えーと あの ブッダの勝負には敗者は得らないという
あの幸福のこのゼロの法則をね
えーと 覆す生き方 で あの説明には入ってありましたけど
あのゼロの法則って何でしょうかっていうね
それは繰り返す必要はないと思いますね
で 一人が豊かになると
もう一人がその分 物がなくなって不幸になるでしょうと
そうすると一人の幸福ともう一人の不幸で足してみたらゼロになるんだっていう
話でね  そういう話になってみると
まあいつでも世界はゼロの状態で
幸福に満たしている人々は増えることはないんですね
で この考え方はこのなんでできているのかというと
やっぱり幸福っていうのはね
金やら財産などなどにあるんだと
私は幸福になったっていうことは
人間がその希望通りの財産とかなんとかに達した時の話なんですね
ですから この一人が金持ちになる場合は
誰か誰か またどこかでその分金がなくなるっていう話でゼロになるんですね
はい それから仏教的な立場から
幸福論というのは何なのかと
あのブッダの勝負っていう風に
なんで始めたかというと
やっぱり人生はなんとしても戦いなんですね
これはなくならないんですよ
何に達しよう 何を得ようとしても
その分努力しないと 精進しないと
頑張らないと達しません
ただ座って待っていると降ってくるということは
まあ全く絶対ありえないんです
祈ればいいかとかね そういうふうなことは決してありえないんですね
我々はもう知識人になりたいと思ったら頑張らなくちゃいけないし
これって勝負ですよ で
財産は十分 収入が十分にあってほしいと思ったら
これがもうまた大変な競争に
勝負になってしまいます
じゃあ健康にいようかなと思ったっても
どちらでも何かを得ようとすると
その分努力はしなくちゃいけない
逆も同じなんですよ 不幸になろうと思ったら
それなりの努力をしなくちゃいけないんです
何もしないでいるとかね
これ 何もしないでいることは
またかえってかなりきついですよね
何かすることも厳しいし
しかし何もしないでそのままでいることはもっと厳しいんです
それで不幸になってしまうんですね
ですから 幸福になろうが不幸になろうが
どちらでも努力によって
成り立っているんだから
人生は勝負なんですね
そこは避けられないんです
しかし 勝負の場合は勝者が出たり
死者が敗者が出たりはするんですね
これがまずい結果なんですね
はい そこでお釈迦様にとられる中道の立場から物事を見ようかなと
まず書いたのは 勘違いの幸福論
俗世間の幸福論というのは本当は勘違いなんですね
金 財産 名誉 権力 社会的な立場などがあることとかね
そんなのを言わなくてもわかっていることで
自分と家族に対する物事は
希望通りに計画通りに進むこととかね
それが幸福だと思っているんですね
自分が好むように生きられること
自分が好きなように生きていられれば
これ幸福やと思っております
幸福の定義は人によって違うので
最初からもう幸福とは何かと理解していないんです
これでわかってほしいのは
これは皆様そのまま思っているわけじゃないんですね
思っているわけじゃないんです
子供がすくすく育ってくれれば幸福だなとみんな思ってないでしょうに
ですから このこうなれば
こうなれば幸福 私が幸福だっていうことも
人それぞれ違います ある人がね
都会で生活できればもう楽しくて幸福やと
ある人が田舎で自分で田んぼを作って
畑作って生活できれば
これはすごい幸せやとかね
これ 幸福論っていうのは一人一人バラバラなんです
ですから 結局は人類が人類にとって何が幸福かっていうことははっきりしていないんです
それを覚えておいてください
幸福は目指しているが
人それぞれ自分勝手な道を目指しているんであって
歩んであって 自分勝手に決めた目的に達しようとしているんであって
それがもう断言的に普遍的に幸福であるという定義がないんですね
だから私が幸福だと思ってやったことが
もしかすると私の不幸になる可能性もありますね
時々子供が何か自分の道を決めたところで
親が大反対する場合もありますね
これはダメですよ ということは
もう親の幸福の定義と子供の幸福の定義
それで違っているんですね
それがまず理解する 人はそれぞれ自分勝手な幸福論を持っている
だから我々は一般的に持っている幸福論そのものもいい加減で
よくわからないんですね
それでよくわからない
幸福に達したいと思っても
どうしますかね それで曖昧で優柔不断で中途半端で
幸福になったか不幸になったか
よくわからなくて終わっちゃいますね
例えば女性がね 結婚すれば子供がいれば幸福だと思ったりして
結婚もする 子供も生まれてくる
これで最悪で 家の管理やら収入が足らないわ
子供が病気になるわ 学校に行きたくないと言うわ
わがまま言うわ 自分勝手なことをするわ
親を怒鳴ったりするわとかね
まあそれでも頑張って自分が年取って
結局幸福になったか不幸になったか
よくわからないでしょうに
言うことを聞かない もう旦那と人と結婚してしまったと
そういうことで この我々は何か幸福だと決まってやってはいるんだけど
それで本当に最終的に幸福になってしまったのか
不幸になってしまったのか
よくわからないことになっているんです
人間というのはみんなそういうことになっているんです
鳩山さんが総理大臣になってよかったのか
本人にとってはね あるいは悪かったのかどうかね
よくわからないんですよ
ですから この偉い人であろうか
偉くない人であろうが
誰でもなんか暗闇でまあ頑張っているだけなんですね
はい そこは第１のポイントね
幸福とは何かっていうことは
我々はよくわからないということ
それでも勘違いの次のステップというのは
この手段が目的になっているんですね
これ 相当の勘違いなんですね
そちらにこの幸福がなくなる原因があるんです
手段が目的になっている
金財産などは幸福になるための手段で道具です
財産というのは道具です
財産 この道具を使用して幸福になるべきなんです
金が道具なんです で それを使っていかに幸福になるのかというのは別な話なんです
道具の使い方によって良い結果になったり
悪い結果になったりする
道具といえば 道具が立派ってだから答え良い結果っていうことはないんですね
道具の使い方なんですね
それほど立派な道具でなくても
もう使い方上手だったら良い結果は出せます
例えば すごい数字の達人が究極的な
ものすごいバック高い筆でなくても
そこら辺にある筆ででも美しい字は書きますよ
あるいはホウキのあれあれ
あれ取って結んで 何かでそれで書いてくれと言ったら
それでも立派な作品を作って見せるんです
ホウキの毛だけでも十分です
で しかし その人はものすごい
2  3万  4万ぐらい値段値札がつく究極な筆も
その人なら使える しかし
その人なら箒の毛を取っても立派な字が書けるというね
だから必要なのは その場合はね
習字の腕が上がっているかないかなんですね
だから 書けない人に何の何の道具をあげたっても
もう書けないんですね
それで大きな問題は 我々は道具を限りなく集めるんです
一度でも道具の使い方を学びましょうとやったことがないでしょう
人間というのは 金の正しい使い方とか
財産の正しい使い方とか
それはやらないんです
知識の正しい使い方は絶対やらないでしょう
ただ 知識も道具です この知識はどう使用するのかと
別に学ばなくちゃいけないんですよ
金も道具です 金はどのように使うのかという
どのように使えば正しいなのか
幸福になるのかって そこを学んでないんですね
だから人類っていうのはもう最悪状態なんです
いきなり道具集めに始まるんです
中学生で人生始めた途端
もう教えられるというのは道具集めなんですね
しかし 使い方は学んでないんです
ですから 俗世間の幸福論は苦しみ
不幸を起こす道なんです
だから この世の中はいつたってもすごい不幸に満ちている
悩み苦しみに満ちている
雑力がもう絶えない 科学を発達したんだからといって
もう地球の人口の 4分の3ぐらい
もう全然 もう全く不幸で生活していて
食べるものもなく 薬もなく
その上もう戦争 戦争 テロ行為とかね
この十年で一日もなかったと思いますね
このひどいテロ行為 どこかでどこかで誰かを爆弾をつけて殺したっていうニュースがない日はないんですね
だから人類どうなっているのかと
地球は平和で豊かでいた日っていうのは一日もないんです
しかし みんな揃って幸福を目指して頑張ってはいるんです
なのに なんで達しないのかと
単純な理由です 道具の収集家で道具を集めるだけで使い方知らないんです
ピストルを集めてもいいんだけど
鉄砲を集めたっても しかし使い方わからなかったら
それで知識の場合はみんなありがたいと思っていますけど
世の中で一番もうひどい悪いことをするのは知識人たちなんです
もう大量破壊兵器を作ったり
化学兵器を作ったり 人類の嘘を言ってひどいことにしたり
ですから 知識でも 使い方がわからないとね
パキスタンでいたんですね
なんかパキスタン国がもう天才だと思っていた
なんか科学者が で 原子力の専門家で
で 何をしたのかと アメリカからも原子原子爆弾とかを作る
作り方 あれやこれや全部もうどんどんとデータを取って
で 原子爆弾を作ることに参加して
そのやり方 あっちこっち売りさばくんです
北朝鮮にこの技術を売ったり
もう他の中東の国々に売ったりとかね
大変なことにしてしまったんですけど
で まあテクノロジー技術あったとしたって
もうなんでこれ何の躊躇もなく
アメリカがね もうあげるのかと
それもすごい知識的な判断でしょ
インドに対抗すればいいや
インドに対抗して何を得るんですかね
どんな利益あるんですかね
何もないでしょう 単純にパキスタンの機嫌を取れば
アメリカの友人になればありがたいと
それならどんなこともしますよってどういうことですかね
いくらやってもパキスタン人はアメリカが好きじゃないんだから
まあとにかく だからそれっての知識の
間違い使い方なんです
知識でする判断では もう全くのひどい結果になったりすることもあります
だから知識であっても使い方というものはあるんです
はい 普通の世間の幸福になる道っていうのは奪い合うことなんですね
道具が幸福だとしているので
その道具を獲得しなくてはならないんですね
金という道具 知識という道具
財産という道具 いろいろ全部道具
道具が幸福だと勘違いしているんだから
そうすると道具を集めなくちゃいけないんですね
他の人も同じものを欲しがりますね
だから この幸福だと思う道具がみんな欲しいと思っちゃうんです
私も金が欲しいと思うと
相手も金が欲しいと思うんですね
もう一人の人 その人も金が欲しくなっちゃうんです
すると人類みんな金が欲しくなって欲しくなっちゃうんですね
しかし 資源にはリミットがあります
金がたくさん欲しいんだからといって
印刷屋さんで印刷してもらってもね
金になりません リミットがあります
日本の政府はね あの印刷工場を持ってますけど
だから印刷しちゃえばいいでしょうに
どんどん それはできないでしょうに
せいぜいね 毎日大量の紙幣がね
使えなくなりますからね
古くなって  それは処分して
その代わりに新しいものを印刷するだけ
だから資源にはリミットがあります
これ みんな限りなく欲しがると
我先にと奪わなくてはならなくなっちゃいます
結局は幸福に至る道は奪い合い合戦になっているんです
幸福になりたいんだから
徹底的に奪い合いで恐ろしい戦いやろうではないかという
どちらにもなりませんね
我々は金のためにすっごい醜い争いをしているんです
はい それからあの幸福の落とし穴ということで
だから私たち俗世間で思っている幸福には
まあ今は今もう言わなくたってわかっていると思いますね
まあ相当落とし穴があるんです
まあ全部言っても時間なくなりますからね
無駄に あのいくつかだけ言います
だからこの奪い合いだから
取られる側 奪われる側が敗者になるんです
だから幸福になろうせとのこと自体で
世界がもう敗者だらけになってしまいますね
不幸が増加していくんです
自分が頑張れば頑張るほど
誰かが不幸になっていくという
敗者が貧困に陥る 必要なものなくなりますからね
不幸になる これ たとえ話で言ったら
この例えでわかりやすいと思いますね
男子 3人が一人の女子に恋に落ち入ったら
結果はどうなるでしょうか？と
そういうことで奪い合いになるでしょうに
だけど  3人の一人が勝利するか
3人とも負けてしまうか
どちらかわからないんですね
だから資源が少ないんです
みんな欲しいと思っているんです
勝者はさらに勝利を得る
敗者はさらに敗北をする傾向もあります
それで世の中を見ると
勝者はね うまくいく人はどんどんどんどんどんどんうまくいっちゃうんですね
ダメになったら 一旦一回だけでもダメになったら
それからダラダラダラダラともう転がってしまいますね
そういう流れがあります
それは心の問題なんです
それは必ずこの敗者が精神的にも負けるからです
いい仕事をして いくらか収入を得ようかなと思ったところで
仕事で失敗してしまう
うまくいかなくなっちゃうと
ものすごく精神的にももう敗者になってますね
それから この仕事ダメだから
じゃあ他のことに挑戦しようかなと思っても
それもうまくいかなくなっちゃうんです
だから世の中を見ると
ある人にとってはどんどん増えていくし
ない人にはもう全部なくなっていくんですね
で そこはこの即席の幸福論で出てくる問題ですね
次の問題は この勝利しても
その勝利はすごく儚いものなんです
財産 権力 能力 家族 健康など
幸福だと思うものすべて消え去るんです
止まらないんです 亡くなってしまいます
幸福を守る 維持 管理をするという新たな問題が起こるんです
ちょっとちょっと人生は成功しても
それからその立場を守らなくちゃいけないわ
維持しなくちゃ 管理しなくちゃいけないわ
だって逃げますからね
まあちょっと可愛いんだからって
野生の動物をね まあもう例えば
例えばシマウマとかね
まあ結構綺麗ですよ 馬よりは
じゃあシマウマを飼ってやろうかなと
ちょこちょこっと まあ禁止ですからね
それでももうちょっと買って 1週間ぐらい面倒見たってもね
逃げるんで シマウマは
飼うことはできないんです
動物園 動物園だけ そこ逃げるところないんだからね
動物園でもね 子供たちにシマウマに乗って一回りしましょうとかね
そういう遊び 訓練はできません
で そんな感じで我々はちょこちょこっと何か得ますけど
やっぱり逃げます ちょっと頑張ったところで健康になったと思っても
この健康が逃げていくんです
それで逃げないようにと
必死にならなくちゃいけないんですね
これは さらに苦しいんですよ
財産を得ることだけじゃなくて
守ることも 勝者でもこれに失敗したら敗者の仲間になります
それで いくらか豊かになった人でも
財産維持管理に失敗したらどうなりますかね
また倒産してしまって
敗者の仲間に入ります
だから大きな問題は新たに生まれてくるんですよ
人生成功しても 成功を守るという宿題がついてくるんです
勝利を得るたびに それを守る苦しみも増えていくんです
それから 自分が勝利得る社会で成功するたびに
新たな問題も守る問題も増えていきます
だからどう評価すればいいかと
1,000万円儲けをすると
それはすごい苦しいことですけどね
ターゲットは高すぎだから
それでその高すぎターゲットの苦しい仕事をして達したとしても
これ守らなくちゃいけないという
これはもう 1万円守ることよりは難しい
管理すること 新たなまた問題も増えていくんです
はい それでは俗世間の幸福論について
次のセクションで不幸に陥る俗世間の勝利者
で 勝利者に付いてくる様々な危険
誰でもこの世の中で成功したいと思ってますけど
それにいろんな危険がついてくるんです
勝利 勝利者はね 成功者は世間の敵なんです
自分がライバル 相手が敵とする
そこで我々は成功しようと思うと
我々にはもう戦わなくちゃいけない相手が成り立っちゃうんです
だから奪い合いの世界だから
だから相手が敵なんですね
ですから 成功しようと思った途端
心の中で他人に対して敵意を抱かなくちゃいけなくなるんです
学校で教えてくれますからね
大丈夫です いかに相手を憎むか
相手に対してもう嫌な気持ちを作るのかということは
まあ学校でも教えてくれるんです
ライバル意識をどんどん叩いて叩いてもう上げるんです
競争心をね だから自分が競争心を持っても踏ん張って頑張るということは
自分の心の中で世界は敵だけやと思わなくちゃいけないんです
やがて世間に対して敵視するようになったり
誰も信頼することができなくなったりするんです
だから あまりにも成功することに必死で
もうすごい激しい競争心でライバルを潰して潰す
進む人が やがて誰も信頼することはできなくなっちゃうんです
それで幸せですかね 敗者の怒り憎しみを買うことになる
そこで 生きる上で成功しようと思って競争していくと
その一歩一歩負けた人が
我々に立って怒ったり
憎んだり 恨んだりするんです
だから自分が世界は世界を敵に回すだけ
敵だと思う 敵視するだけではなくて
実際も世界が自分の敵になっているんです
私はこの心の立場から喋ってますから
自分の心も汚れてしまって
他人の心も汚すことになっちゃうんです
一般的に世間の怒り 嫉妬
恨みの的になってしまう
はい 競争の場合は競争相手がいますから
人類は競争相手になりませんね
しかし 自分がいくら何人かとの競争で勝ち取って成功しましても
この成功者に対して世界が恨むんですね
関係ない人も 私たちも自分たちに関係ないんだけど
ものすごく抜群に成功している人々の悪口をです
親切というのはもうないんです
はい それの対策方法っていうのは
やっぱり競争することではなくてね
慈悲の実践ですよ それは仏教の答えですね
我々は慈悲の実践しながら生きていなくちゃいけないんですね
でないと この猛毒がなくなりません
これって猛毒なんで 自分が敵敵で生きると
自分が全く誰も信じられなくなりますよ
時々 成功している家族の中では
子供のことを信頼しないんですよ
親が この人にこの会社
この財産を任せちゃえばどうするでしょうかねとかね
全部壊してダメにするかもしれませんとかね
あるいは奥さんがまあちょっと金を余分に使っちゃうと
いろいろおしゃれグッズに
この人はもう私の財産を破壊するぞとかね
思ったりして管理するんですね
あなたは月々そこまでやとかね
あの有名な話で 世界で一番ものすごい金持ちのオナシスというイタリア人がね
ケネディ大統領の奥さんと結婚してまったでしょ
ジャクリーン・ケネディと
それでジャクリーン・ケネディもかなり精神的な不安定で
まあすごいどうにもない我が強くて
もう 恐ろしいんです すごい金持ちなんですけど
微塵も幸福を感じてなかったと
人生は そこで彼女はどれほど我が強いかというと
もうどこかのデザイナーが新しいデザインして服を作ったならば
自分が気に入ったならばそれ買いますけど
その作る品物は全部買うんです
なぜかというと そうすると他の人は同じデザインの服は着ることはできないんです
自分と同じ服をもう一人の人が着ているのを見る
見たくはないんですね
偉いんだから それ たった一着の服にどれぐらいお金がかかると
想像できないでしょうね
そのデザイナーが作った品物を全部丸ごと買ってしまいますから
じゃあ買って その服どうするのかと
同じものの 40着買いましたと
全く同じものを それであの世界一の金持ちのオナシスもこれが大変やと
自分が倒産する羽目になるんです
と思って お金を使えないようにもう
もう何て言いますか もう管理しておいたんです
それでこの人がものすごくかって
もう離婚したみたいかな
もう今はもう関係ない話ですけど
だから 成功しようと必死になってくると
やがて自分のお坊さんも自分の子供さえも信頼できなくなっちゃうんです
これって幸福ですかね
奥さんは信じられません
子供たちはもう信頼できません
友達のことを信頼するはずもないでしょうに
他人を信頼するはずもないでしょうに
これで生きていられると思いますかね
だから やっぱり慈悲の実践で生きてなくちゃいけないんですけど
誰もやらないんですからね
はい 次の問題は心が汚れてしまうんですね
汚れた心で競争に挑まなくてはならないんです
最初からもう敵意を持って勉強しなくちゃいけない
ライバル意識を持って勉強しなくちゃいけない
試験に試験を受けなくちゃいけない
会社で仕事をしなくちゃいけない
だから人生スタートする時点で心を汚してるんです
汚した心で頑張らなくちゃいけないんです
成功したところでエゴの錯覚が強化するんです
もし大体汚した心で頑張ると
あまり成功しないんです
もし成功したら 俺がやったぞと
私は負けは知りませんよとかね
すごくエゴが自我が強化していくんです
それでやられます 結局は幸福を守らなくてはならないので
欲と執着が生まれてくるんです
財産 道具をたくさん収集したら
これ守らなくちゃいけないんですね
守るためには この財産に徹底的に執着しなくちゃいかないんです
財産にすごく欲を抱かなくちゃいけないんですね
それでさらに心が汚れていくんです
競争して生きる場合は
常に心の不安 悩み 落ち込むなどを経験するんです
それで終わらない 競争の生き方をすると
その時点からも不安なんです
負けたらどうしようかと
このタイトルは来年奪われたらどうしようかと
世界一というタイトルを取っても
その日からまあ挑戦する相手が出てくるんだから
だから安心できませんね
だから不安が増えるんです
だから競争する生き方っていうのは
心の安らぎ 幸福 安心感を得られません
成功すればするほど悩み派手になるんです
苦しみ派手になるんです
成功しないとまた悩み派手になる
苦しむ羽目になる それで幸福を楽しめなくなりますね
競争で忙しいんです 競争心で生きるから
心の安らぎの代わりに落ち着きがなくなる
不安に陥る で 競争心で生きて頑張って頑張って成功していきますが
どんどんどんどんどんどんもう不安ばっかし
これあの それでみんなまた誤解して
あのもう金がこの 1,000万ではなくて
まあ 5億円とかね  10億円とかね
あれば大丈夫やと だから大量にあった方が安心やと
あれも勘違いで リーマン・ブラザーズは一番わかりやすい例でしょう
もう人類に信じる信じられる量の金ではないんですよ
あったのは  1週間も経たないうちに全部なくなって
パーになって 世界までひどい目に遭って遭わせてしまいました
自分は汚い人々だから
このズケは関係ない人々に回すんです
あの仏教でもあの インドの物語がありましてね
あの 八十億両の金持ちの息子が
また同じ八十億両 金貨ですからね
で 金持ちの娘さんと結婚したという話があります
これ結構使う話で でお釈迦様の時代でね
それで両親がまあこの金はどう使っても使いきれませんよと言って
息子にも教育させなかったし
金の使い方を教えてあげなかったんですね
お嬢さんにも その家が金の使い方を教えていなかった
これぐらい金あればどう使ったって使い切れませんよと
親がそう考えての親が頑張って金を儲けたんだから
いくらか金ってどういうものか知ってるんですけど
この二人が結婚して 両家の親が死んで間もないうちに
すべて財産がなくなって
貧乏になって乞食になってしまったんです
それである日 お釈迦様で祇園精舎で
で 人々 まああの昼ご飯終わってから
お釈迦様はちょこちょこっとアーナンダ尊者ともう前歩いたんです
それでお坊さんたちは托鉢してご飯もらいますから
まあ 1 食分を食べて 残りは貧しい人々にあげるんです
だから乞食の人々はたくさん集まるんですね
お坊さんたちは街に出て托鉢して帰る
お坊さんたちにはお布施もらいますけど
乞食には誰もあげる気にはならないんですね
それでみんなご飯食べて
残りはみんなに配ってあげる
で アーナンダ尊者も自分の残ったご飯を誰かにあげると
お釈迦様も一緒にいるんですね
で 若い二人がまあ乞食
二人がお坊さんたちは食べ残したご飯を食べているんです
そしたらお釈迦様がアーナンダ
あの二人知ってる？あまり知りませんと
あの二人はこの西条で一番金持ちでしたよと
この二人とも 八十億金貨の財産を持っていて
女の人も男の人も で 結婚して間もないうちに
今こうなっているんだと
この二人がね 生き方を知らなかったんだから
世俗的にも大失敗したんだと
あるいはその財産 全部使い方がわからないながら捨てましょうと
道具ばっかり意味がないと思って出家したならば
解脱に達する可能性もあったよと
しかし 両方できないんだと
今は ですから この仏教は昔からそれを言ってますよ
むちゃ金があるんだからといって安心することはできないんですよ
皆様にでも何億円かお金入っちゃうと
どうしてもこれを投資しちゃうんです
した しなくても もう向こう側からいろんな金融関係から来て
もうものすごくギャーギャーギャーギャーと言って使わせるんです
あっという間 消える可能性があります
政府も誰もこの金使わないで置いておくことはもう良くないと思っているんです
金は動かさなくちゃいけないんですね
だから個人の貯金は何としてでも使いたいんです
国民年金などなどね ものすごいお金が集まり入りますけど
全て無駄遣いしてなくしたのは
もうそれは政府の管理
公務員たちのやり方でね
どうでもよくね 金はというね
結局一般国民にはもう年金が入らなくない
入らないという状態なの
それは数字でごまかそうとしているんですね
騙そうとしているんです
それはありえないんですけどね
そういうことだから 年金払ったんだからもらうんだというね
そんな保証はないんですよ
世の中では ですから このたくさんあれば安心だということもものすごい誤解なんです
それであの ジャクラインさんの話も例で出しましたでしょうに
そういう人々はどれほど不安で不幸で苦しんで生きているのかと
億単位でお金使っているのに
何の楽しみも何の幸福も感じないんです
世界を敵に回っているので
落ち着いて幸福を楽しめない
そこで頑張って豊かになっても
自分がたくさん敵を作っているんだから
まあ落ち着けないんです
自由には動けないんです
プライベートの警備を警備会社頼まなくちゃいけないんです
どこに行っても 大量のボディーガードと一緒に行かなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
だからどこに行ったても楽しくないんです
有名なスターが日本に来て
じゃあディズニーランドに行きましょうと言ったら
マイケル・ジャクソン
ああいうような人で 他の人はあまり行かないんだけど
もう全部 1 日 何聞いてるんですか？え？貸し切りにしなくちゃいけないんですね
それって楽しいんですかね？自分のボディーガードのグループと一緒に朝から晩までその人々の顔を見ているんだから
これは面白い これ面白い
微塵も楽しめないと思いますよ
ディズニーランドに我々に行ったら楽しいなのは
全く知らない人々いっぱい
まあガチャガチャガチャガチャ遊んだり
叫んだり 楽しくいるんだから
なんとなくその雰囲気でこちらも楽しい
子供たちが遊んでいるセクションに行ったら
自分たちは大人なのに
もう知らない子供たちがものすごくはしゃいで遊んでいるのを見ると楽しみがいるのに
ですから あまりにも成功しすぎると
結局は全部楽しみが消えてしまうんです
この世で楽を得ても 万が一この世ですごく楽しく贅沢に陥って
誰にも殺されないでね
生活したとしても 心が汚れているんだから
一生汚れていますから
心は 1 日で汚れたわけじゃなくて
長い人生 ずっと汚れた心でしっかりと頑固に生きてきたんだから
死後は失敗する 大敗者になるんです
あの あの聖書で言っているような感じなんです
金持ちが天国に行くということは
ラクダが針の穴を通るぐらいの楽なもんやと
ですから やっぱり最終的な結果は失敗
敗者ということなんです
勝者も敗者も苦しみにたどり着く
ですから 我々俗世間の幸福論で生きてみると
みんな最後に同じ結果なんです
苦しみにたどり着くだけ
敗者には現実は苦しいんですね
人生に負けたら まあもう苦しいんですよ
仕事に失敗すれば もう収入がなかったら
もう夢でもなく もう現実的に苦しい
それで心が汚れるんですよ
私にはあれもない これもないというふうに悩まなくちゃいけないし
頑張ってもうまくいかないんだと落ち込まなくちゃいけないし
誰かのせいで自分に仕事がないと思ったり
勘違いしたりもする 世界が悪い
人が悪いとか それで無差別殺人事件まで起こしたりする
だから敗者は現実的にも苦しいし
その現実的な苦しみによってどんどん心汚れて
もう犯罪までしてしまうんです
他人を恨んだり 嫉妬したり
また自分に対して卑下になったり
自分を憎んだりする紙になります
これ 敗者の結果ですね
負ける人の結果ですね
人を恨むか 自分を恨むか
あるいは両方恨むか どちらにしても心は汚れているんです
簡単に罪を犯せるようなものになります
心が汚れたので この世の苦しみの後
死後大敗者になるんです
はい あの 数学的に言えば随分簡単です
この世で成功すれば 結果として死後大敗者になります
この世で失敗すれば死後大敗者になります
だから 俗世間でいう幸福論
幸福論に乗っていても乗らなくても結果は同じです
いわゆる乗るんですよ
世間の幸福に金儲かりましょうとかね
豊かになろうぜとかね
みんな乗ったら負ける人も勝つ人もありますね
だから 負けても勝ってもご褒美は同じです
そうだったらバカバカらしいでしょう
ゴルフトーナメントで１位になった人にも
最後になった人にも 最下位の人にも同じ賞金だったら
大学受験したら合格者も落第者もみんな大学に入られますよと
というと 何のために競争するんですかね
ですから 世の中の世間の幸福論というのは
もう結局はそんなもんなんです
最後に同じ結果になるんです
この勘違いっていうのは
そういうことなんです
幸福だと思ってるんだけど
それが勘違いで 最後に不幸になりますよと
最終的には終着点は不幸だよということになります
次の問題がありまして
この依存症 それは別な項目で理解した方がいいんですね
財産 家族などに幸福があると思う
で これは物に依存 喜びを感じることですね
依存するんですね 家族がいれば幸せやと思って結婚する人は
この結婚生活に依存しているんです
金があれば楽しいなと思ったら
金に依存しているんです
自分の幸福 喜び 楽しみなどは
外のものが与えてくれる
与えていることになります
だから法則成り立つんです
私の幸福は外のものが与えてくれるんだと
あのキリスト教とか一神教ではそれをはっきりしていますね
幸福を与えてくれるものであると
恵みであると 財産 名誉
権力 家族などの奴隷になって心の自由がなくなるんです
そうなってくると その楽しみを与えてくれるものから離れないでしょ
これは外のものだから
気をつけてもう機嫌を取っておかないと
結婚したら幸福で生きていきたいと思うならば
相手の機嫌をむちゃくちゃ機嫌を取っておかないと
うまくいかないんでしょうに
それでどうなるのかというと
自分の自由がなくなるんです
自分が奴隷になっちゃうんです
そういう苦い経験というのは
女性にも男性にもあると思いますよ
旦那の機嫌を取りますと
そうすると家庭安定して幸福やと思うと
結局は奴隷になります
女性も男性も奥さんの機嫌を取っておかなくちゃと思ったら
もうまたそこで奴隷になってしまいます
もう自由がなくなるんです
同じ金であろうか 知識であろうか
名誉であろうか 権力であろうか
社会的立場であろうか
これが私が欲しい 私の幸福の基やと思っちゃうと
そのそのものの奴隷になるんです
だから この 物というか
道具ですね が 変化しただけで
自分の幸福が苦しみに変わります
これ とっても危険なことなんです
例えば結婚して もう子供を作ろうかなと思っている途中で
一人が亡くなると 突然
もう耐えがたい苦しみになるんです
あるいはもう 30代の二十歳のもう二十歳ではなくて
20代ので結婚して 奥さんが子供を産んですぐ亡くなったと
病気で これから大変な苦しみになる
あるいは突然自分の子供が死んじゃったと
突然会社が倒産しましたと
大変ですよ この道具はもうなくなったら
もういともたってもいられなくなります
それにもお釈迦様 仏典では
まあお釈迦様がとウィサーカ夫人の間の対話がありまして
この依存症ってどれほどひどいかというエピソードがあります
このウィサーカ夫人というのは
ものすごい富豪のすごい金持ちの人で
お釈迦様は女性の信者さんの間で第一として位もありましたし
でお釈迦様より結構年下でしたけど
まあまあなんかお釈迦様もなんか娘みたいな感じで
あのウィサーカ夫人もお釈迦様のことを父親みたいな感じで
まあいろいろ言ったり
あれこれなんですね で
突然 このウィサーカ夫人が 1週間もお釈迦様に会いに行かなかったんです
1週間経ってから会いに行ったんです
行ったら顔色がひどくて
髪の毛がむちゃくちゃ乱れて
服が汚れて 痩せてもうやつれて
もうひどい状態 もうインドのもう節制の美人だったからね
逆に で お釈迦様 あんたどうなっているのかと
もうやつれているし 服が汚れているし
服はボロボロでしょうに
髪の毛が乱れて 顔色が悪くて
目の力も全部なくなってひどい状態だよ
そんなことなく言ったんです
そしたら彼女はお釈迦様
こんな状態にならざるを得ないんだと
私はなんで？と聞いたら
孫がいたんだよ ものすごく可愛かったと
一番可愛い 可愛くて遊び回る
でっかい家だからね お城中大騒ぎして遊び回るとこれ気持ちいいんですよ
だって偉い人 家の中ではそんなに気持ちに劣っている
誰も立ちませんだからね
緊張しているんだから
ちっちゃな子供にはどうったことないし
だからもうはしゃいだい放題はしゃいでいる時で
突然病気になって死にましたと
これはいともたってもいられない状態で苦しんでいるんだと
そしたらお釈迦様 何のことなく
あ そう その孫がすごく可愛かったんですかね
って言ったら 何をおっしゃるのかと
もうこれという文句言うところは何もなかったんだと
もう完璧 可愛くてたまらなく可愛いんだと
ああそう ということは
そんなぐらいの性格の孫だったら
二人いたってもあなたにとっては重くないでしょうにと
言ったらすぐ喜んじゃったんだよ
そうそうそう もう二人がいたならば
もう最高やと うん まあそう
幸福は 2倍になるんだと
じゃあ 3人いたら  3人だったらもう 3倍でしょうにと
もう金があるんだからね
だったらもう あんなあなたの亡くなった孫のような孫があなたに 100人いればどうですか？ と
200人いればどうと
本人がもう全然何のことなくお釈迦様の話に乗ってるんです
それだったらものすごい楽しいです
もうイメージ膨らみ膨らんでるんです
一人の子供からこれぐらい幸福を感じたんだから
300人ぐらいいたらむっちゃ楽しいでしょうと
それでお釈迦様がこの最上の人口ぐらい孫たちがいればどうしますか？と
それだったら私は世界一幸福なものであると言うんですね
ああそう あのね 君 知ってますかね？この歳上で 1 日何人死ぬんですかと
言ったら 10人も死ぬし
100人も死ぬ場合もあるし
しかし  1 日でも人を死なない日はないんだよ
そうでしょ ということは
君に最上の人口と同じぐらい孫たちがあったら
あんたどれぐらい悩んで済むのかと
一人が死んで 1週間も経ってもご飯食べてないんだからね
言った通り 今まで膨れ上がってきたあの楽しみ
突然恐怖感に変わっちゃって
とんでもないことだと
私ほど馬鹿がいるのかと
で さっとあの楽しみが消えちゃったんです
だから言ってるでしょうにと
愛着は捨てなさいと この愛着から苦しみが生まれるんだよと
死ぬものは死にますよと
死んじゃ消えたら でもなんであんた苦しむ？愛着があるからでしょうに
別に殴られてるからじゃないでしょうに
わがまま言ってるからじゃないでしょうに
子供が生きてる場合はわがまま言うわ
泣き出すわ いろんなことを言うんだから苦しいんでしょうし
それは何もないんだから
死んじゃったら それでも悲しみで激しいんですね
その悲しみは激しくなるのは愛着があるんだからでしょうに
言ってるではないかと
言ったところで 彼女はもうすごい心が戻って
また戻りましたけど お釈迦様のこの厳しいカウンセリングで
しかし そのエピソードで何を教えてくれるのかというと
好みのもの 希望通りのものを得たということは
それぐらい危険性も持っているんです
ちょっと変わったらどうなるかわからなくなっちゃう
途方に暮れてしまうんです
せっかく念願叶えてマイホーム作っても
もしちょっと何かなったら
ローン払えなくなったら
もう全部終わり あるいは地震でも起きてひび割れが入ったら
あの悲しみは並大抵のものじゃないんですよ
念願のマイホームができたと楽しいんですよ
しかし すごい危険が待ち構えているんです
はい それが依存症で説明してまいります
幸福がものに依存することで成り立つんだよと
ウィサーカ夫人の話では
ウィサーカ夫人の人生がもうなんとなくつまらなかったでしょうね
毎日忙しくて でも孫が生まれちゃったんだからね
孫 結構いたみたいですけど
で だいたいいろいろブッダ読んでみると
かなり孫がダメになったみたいですね
あまりもウィサーカ夫人が面倒を見てあげたりして
で わがまま放題で  ちょっと育ちが悪くなったケースもありますけど
一人の女の子がね それも孫でしたけど
まあ可愛い可愛い あれやこれやとかね
何でも言うことやってあげたりして
すごいわがままになっちゃったんです
それで お釈迦様と一緒に行ったか
他のサーリプッタサンジャと一緒に行ったかってわからないんだけど
その家に托鉢にちっちゃな出家した子供も行ったんですね
子供がもう出家しているんですけど
自分と同じ年の女の子がニコニコと遊んだり笑ったりして
で その子はニコッと笑ったんですね
笑ったら 女の子はもうお前はハゲやと
ときついことを言ったんですね
そしたら子供も負けず嫌いで言い返しちゃって
子供って出家してますけどね
言い返しちゃったんです
したら一番もうものすごい大金持ちのね
家のお嬢さんにね そういうきつい言葉言ったら
普通は大変なことになりますけど
これ喧嘩になります ウィサーカ夫人はさっさともう孫の立場と肩を取るんですね
肩を取って もう沙弥のお坊さんにあなた方は出家してね
そういうことを言ってはいけませんでしょうと言うんですね
言ったら この子も負けません
もうウィサーカ夫人にまで悪口
なんであんたその子の肩持つんですかと
その子ではないかと 先に私に悪口言ったのはと
言って この話はうまくいかないんですね
ウィサーカ夫人がやっぱり自分の孫が正しいと言いたくなってるんで
愛着があるんだから お坊さんに対しては尊敬ありますけど
まあ沙弥にはちょっと間違ったら
それはもうなんとか躾しなくちゃいけないと偉そうなことを思っているんです
3人が喧嘩するところで
お釈迦様にこれ何とかしてくださいと言われたら
お釈迦様は何したかというと
いきなり沙弥の肩を取ったんです
だから育ちが悪いのは
あの子供 出家していた男の子じゃないんです
それはちゃんともうしっかりと育ているんです
あの子は不公平なことにはもう立ち向かっていうね
は認めないという態度なんです
お釈迦様は あのね 私の子供に
彼らが財産捨てて 髪の毛を剃って出家して修行しているんだよと
その人にハゲというのはどういうことかと
それほど侮辱があるのかと
そこで出家は侮辱することが悪いでしょうにと
言ったらまあウィサーカ夫人にどうすることもできなくて
だからそこで私読み取っているのは
このおばさんのね 孫をあまりにもかわいがって結構ダメにしてんじゃないかなと
まあごく普通のまあありがちの話ですからね
やっぱりおばちゃんにとっては孫が可愛いんだからね
もうダメになりますよ
はい まあそれでまあどうでもいい話で時間なくなっただけで
あの 我々欲しがるもの
好きなもの 手に入ったとしても
喜ぶのはちょっと注意しないと
ちょっとでもそれが変わっちゃうと大変なことになります
例えば分割払いで高価なカバンを買ったとしましょう
ほんのちょっとでも傷とかなんとかついたらどうしますかと
もう大変なショックでしょう
3,000円ぐらいの安いカバンを買ったところで
ちょっとちょっと傷ついたりしましたよ
まあそれ捨てちゃえば捨てます
何のこともなく やっぱり安いものはそんなもんじゃ
まあいいやと捨てますけど
20万円のカバンどうしますかね？傷がついたら
傷がついたら まあショックでしょう
落ち込みますよ だってお金も払わなくちゃいけないんだから
またすきすき そういうことで
このこの変わると 我々は精神的に病気になって落ち込んで
人生ダメになってしまうという危機がついています
この依存症で物に依存すると
はい そういうことで ちょっと一旦休憩して
次のセクション始まります
はい 10分は経過しました
はい 今まで俗世間の幸福論の間違い
俗世間の幸福の道を歩んだら
みんな結局一緒に道連れになって不幸に陥るんだと
だから相当な勘違いだという話でした
はい それからブッダの教えからいろいろ考え
提案を出して このプログラムはどのように改良するのかという
だから一番先にいるのは
この俗世間の幸福の道に関わる危険副作用を最小限にしてみることですね
第1に考えてほしいことは
このなかなか世の中やらないんですよ
必需品のリミット 人に限りなくものが必要ではありません
限りなくものが必要ということは嘘です
そんなことはないんです
自分の 心が満足を感じる
自分に管理できる範囲で希望するもののリミットをつけなくてはならないんです
自分が満足できる範囲で
それから財産管理できる範囲で
まあこの程度で十分やと
このリミットをつけないと
生きていられないんです
これは世間では大反対で
その考えには リミットをつけるなよと
いくらでも儲かりなさいよ
これはもう仏教は認めません
これは間違いだと 誰かがもう限りなくものを奪おうとすると
どれほどの人が不幸になるのかと
人を不幸に陥れる道が善ですかね
財産を相手から奪う取るものではありません
ですから 最初からもうライバルだ
競争しなくちゃ そこは捨てた方がいいんです
財産っていうのは奪うものでありません
相手が与えるものです
これってものすごい大事なポイントなんです
私に必要な幸福で 楽しく満足して生きていられるために必要なものはすべて与えるものなんです
奪うものじゃないんです
しかし 一神教と違います
一神教ではもう神が与えるんだと
おねだりすればいいという話で終わりますけど
仏教ではこの神が与える話がないんです
与える人ははっきりしています
他の人々 他の生命 飼っている猫も我々の楽しみを与えているんだから
その条件状況を作ることが自分の仕事です
それで 私たちの仕事は誰かを倒すことじゃないんですよ
抗争で自分が勝って相手を負ける
負け 負けに負けるようにすることじゃないんです
与えられる条件を作るんです
だから 根本的に仏教の富める道っていうのは
もう全く根本的に違うんです
相手に打ち勝つんじゃないんです
打ち勝って相手の金を奪うと
だから仏教では賭け事は大反対でしょ
それは奪うことだから
ちょっとしたごまかしで
だから我々の仕事というのは与えなく与えなくてはいけない条件を作るんです
まあ例えば まあなんですかね
人の髪の毛を切ったりする能力がある人がいる
その人は一生懸命修行して
しっかりと一人前で もう人の髪の毛はデザインしてカットすることはできる
でも自分にはできません
よくわからない どんな髪型がいいかどうかも
で その人 あの人はすごい人気もあって
有名で かなり腕がよろしいと
そういったところで じゃあ私の髪の毛もお願いしますと
言うと その人は自分の能力を見事に活かしていい結果は出すんですね
そうするとこちらがやっぱりお金あげなくちゃと
で 決まった額ではなくて
もうちょっと もうちょっと入れた方がいいんじゃないと
その人を喜ばせてあげなくちゃという気分になるんです
そこは何も奪ってないんです
だから仕事っていうのは
誰かライバルを倒すことじゃなくて
相手に与えざるを得ない
相手が喜んで与える条件を作ることです
だから 仕事の定義を覚えておいてください
仏教は根本的にそこが違うんですね
いつでもいい ですから
与えるとは そこはちょっと勉強した方がいいんですね
与えられていないものを取ることは非道徳
罪ですね 仏教では五戒の2番目ですからね
最初から仏教はそういう世間論に入ってるんです
幸福になる道に入ってます
だから戒律を守るだけでも人は幸福になりますよと
はっきり言ってますから
五戒を守っただけで十分だよと
もうむちゃくちゃ幸福になりますよと言っているのは
どういうことかと大体わからないでしょう
与えられてないものは取ってはいけませんと
みんなやってますから
余分に取ろうとする ろくな仕事もしていないのに
もうたくさん給料を期待する
相手が喜んで自分に財産などをね
与えるようにするんです
だから相手が喜んで自分に財産とか
たくさんありますからね
知識でも何でも 例えば飼っている猫にも遊びなさいよとかね
これ飛びなさいよと言ったってもやってくれないでしょうに
だから猫が輪っかを跳ぶ
跳ぶ 通して輪っかを通って跳ぶように気分を作らなくちゃいけないんです
その気分を作っちゃうと
喜んで飛んでくれるんです
だから動物と喋れないんだから
我々はいくらかその相手の気分変えるでしょ
だったら人間との付き合いの場合でも
物事を喋り合っても分かりづらいんだから
人間っていうのは 動物は理解しますよ
喋れないんだけど 人間での喋って喋られますけど
人をいうことは理解しないんですね
だから動物とコミュニケーションというのは随分簡単でシンプルでできます
人間とはコミュニケーション取れないんですね
ですから我々はこの犬に
猫に イルカにやらせているように喜んでやっています
イルカさんたちも喜んで飛んだり
あれやこれやとかね あれ
苦しいと思わないんです
水族館のいるイルカが
もうこれが苦しいやと思っちゃうと
すごくストレスが溜まって食欲がなくなっちゃう
病気になりますからね
それは大体ないでしょうに
飼育館が来るともう喜んじゃって
お客さんの前に来る前に中で水槽にいますからね
そこではしゃいでるんです
遊びたくて だからドアを開けた途端
喜んで入り込んで キーってスピード出して
強烈なスピードでもう３回ぐらい回ったりして
お客さんに水をかけたりとかね
喜んでいるんですね だからイルカが喜んで
我々に楽しみを与えているんですよ
それで幸福でしょ あー楽しかったってことになるでしょうに
だからまあわかりやすい幸福になる正しい道は
人間にも動物と同じく扱ってください
ということになりますけど
で それは あまり失礼な単語かもしれませんだけど
やっぱり人間の気持ちを変えるんですよ
喜んで与える気持ちに
変えるんですね その場合
気をつけなくちゃいけないのは詐欺
詐欺師も人を喜ばせますけどね
それはそれは騙し取ることだから
もうもうとんでもない罪でしょうに
だからそれはありえないんですね
この人にはこのお金をあげなくちゃいけないんだよと
その分 大変いろんなことをして助けてくれましたよ
という気持ちを作ることなんですね
そうなると 相手がパートナーであって
競争相手ライバルではなくなるんです
簡単に問題解決します
もう敵ばっかり作ってた人が何のこともなく
仕事は激しく変えることもなく
そのままでいながら 世界は自分のパートナーにする
もうライバル意識がなくなる
競争心が消えてしまう
どれほど楽と思いますかね
ほんのちょっと変えるだけなんです
しかし このほんのちょっとを変える場合は
その裏の理論というのはものすごい
世間の理論とは全く正反対なんです
自分の財産を守る苦しみも減るんです
自分が正しく与えられたもので生活する場合は取る必要ないんで
誰かが あれ私があげたものだからと
だからよく使ってほしいという気持ちでしょ
あの人の家に入って家を破って金を取るってことはなくなっちゃうんです
与えられたものはだいたい取る気にはなりません
だから財産を守る あの苦しみがもう半減のところじゃないんですよ
ものすごく減っているんです
だから そのようにすごいシンプルな改革改良プログラムで
人生はぐるっと幸福の方向へ変えられます
相手から何も見返りを期待しないで与えることは優れた善行になります
はい 今まで言ったのは何か期待しているんです
イルカさんの機嫌を取ったのは
イルカさんが芸をやったら楽しいんです
だから期待があるんですね
だから期待があっても先に与えなくちゃいけないんです
与えたら向こう側が喜んで与えてくれる
しかし もう一つ与え方があります
相手から何も期待しない
見返り期待しない ただ与える
それが優れた善行為なんです
善行為とは 真の幸福をもたらす原因
力なんです 善行為っていうのはお釈迦様の定義なんですけど
スカッセイタンガディワタナンヤジダンプンニャンという
徳というのは幸福の同義語であると
お釈迦様はおっしゃってますよ
だから善行為しなさいということは
幸福になりなさいという意味なんです
幸福になりなさいと言ったらどうやって？という疑問が出てくるでしょう
なりたいんだけど どうやってと
それをまとめて善行為しなさいということで終わっちゃいます
善行為とは幸福の同義語であると
ですから 善行為の場合は
レベル高いの方がレベル高いの幸福をもたらすんです
レベル高い与えることっていうのは
見返りも期待しないことなんです
それでまた世の中にある問題が解決する
様々な原因で幸福にならない弱い人に与えることはより優れています
だから期待しないで与える場合は
期待できそうもない人に与えるんです
不幸に陥っている人々
いろんなもう自然災害やらいろんなことでまあ大変なことになっている人っていくらでもありますけど
そういう人々にいろんなことを奉仕して与える
向こう側から何も期待してないんです
例えば地震が起きて避難している人々に
食料やら水やらテントやらどーんと来る
はい このテントはこれぐらいお金になりましたから
お金を返して返ってちょうだいとかね
言わないでしょ この水 1本はこれぐらい 200円だよと言って
家も潰れて食べるものもなくて
飲み物もなくて困ってる人に言う
言わないでしょうに だからこれが与える場合は
いろんな原因で どうしようもなくなって生きていられない人々っていうのは結構いるんです
障害を持って生まれるわ
自然災害に遭遇するわ
寒気になるわ あるいは国の土地はなかなか農業に適していないわとかね
バングラデシュみたいな
まあもう突然洪水で全部もう畑
農作物全部流されてしまうわとかね
そういう まあどうしようもないんです
その場合は ただ障害を持って生まれたら
その人にとってはどうしようもないでしょうに
そうすると 力のあるできる人は助けるのは当たり前なんですけど
それも与えることなんですが
相手から何か期待してはないんです
それはすごい優れている善行なんですね
それでこの世界の不公平がなくなるんです
世界の経済不振やら不公平やら
一部幸福になると一部が不幸になる
この悪循環が軽論です
なんとなく幸福になっている人々は
幸福にならない人々を助けてあげたりするんです
そうすると恨みっこはないんです
競争で負けたんだけど
負けた人は何も賞金もらわないんだけど
自分の賞金の一部をね
あげると そうすると 勝った人に対して恨みは作れないでしょうに
自分が幸福のポテンシャルを持つだけではなく
世間の世間を味方に変えることにもなるんですね
その生き方をすると いわゆる見返り期待しないででも与えることをすると
自分が幸福になる ポテンシャル
パワー エネルギーはものすごい持っているんです
だからいくらでも財産は磁石のように
幸福が磁石のように寄ってくるんです
それで楽になるんです
やみくもに頑張らなくてもいいことになるんです
それだけじゃなくて 豊かな人ってには恨み買うだけでしょ
不幸な人に この場合は逆になるんです
みんな自分の仲間で 味方でもう誰の恨みも買わない
で 法則はギブアンドテイクですが
世間はテイクだけで生活しようとするんです
まあよく皆さんが知っているこのギブアンドテイクという法則がありますよ
世の中で これは人間悪いとこもあれが悪いともないんでしょうね
法則です ギブアンドテイク
与えていただくというね
しかし 私たちの心の中はどうですかね
腹の中はテイクだけなんです
取りたいだけで頭の中で働くのは
あの会社のあの仕事に就いたら
これぐらい給料もらえる額を考えるんです
で いろんなこの勉強する人々の中でね
いろんな専門勉強とかいろいろありますからね
あのエカウンタンツという会計士の
まあちょっとレベル高い
そういう資格でも取ったら随分給料は高いんです
あの なんかイギリス系系系等で何か試験がありますね
なんたかなんとか試験
そこは大体年で修了できますけど
まあ最終修了するためにはまた一年間仕事じゃなくちゃいけない
それ終わったらもう給料が抜群
そうなってくると みんなじゃあ何としてでもこの試験を合格しようと
なんで 私も聞いたんで
友達に そういう試験を受けている人々がね
まあその連中 まあいろんな外国で仕事をしてボロ儲けしていますけど
やっぱり最初からもうあんた方は大学出て仕事をしたってもね
これなかなか大変でしょうにと
まあ資格取るのも難しくてね
当たりだよと あれはと
でもこれは簡単にこの資格取れますよと
取れたらあんた初期給料も初任
何給料というんですか？最初の給料もあなた方の給料よりは高いだよと
で やっぱり人間というのは最初にもうテイクしか考えていないんです
取ることをしか だからこの仕事にどれぐらい責任があるのか
どれぐらい真剣に仕事をするのか
それは関係ないんですね
だから経理会社に頼んでも
会社が政府に調べられたり
いろいろでしょ 逮捕されたり
罰金払う羽目になったり
ちゃんと経理会社がついてるならばね
まあ税金は払ってないんだとかね
ちゃんと報告していないんだとか
そんなことありえないでしょうに
だから自分の仕事の責任というのはもう考えていないんです
給料だけ 収入だけ 結構失敗しますよ
普通の商売を始めても
月々これぐらいの収入を上げますよとかね
先にテイクばっかり考えるんです
だからもうすごく汚れてますよ
すごく醜いんです それで人間みんなそういうこと
私に何がくれるのかと
先にそれ ですから法則はギブアンドテイクですが
世間の幸福論の人間ができればテイクだけで生きていきたいと思っているんです
仕事はしたくない 給料は欲しいなんです
ボロ儲けを期待するんです
何かを与えること 投資することは避けられない
やむを得ない場合はテイクアンドギブという順番にします
まあ例えば商売しようかなと思ったっても
店を買わなくちゃ 買ったり
もうなんとかもう家賃取ったりしなくちゃいけないし
品物を買わなくちゃいけないし
これ避けられないんですね
その場合だけ 嫌で嫌で投資するんですけどね
できれば避けたいんですね
自分が投資する分は もうできるできるだけもうもう減らしたいんです
時々そういう怪しい人々は
銀行からローン取ったり
いろいろなところからローンとローンではなくて
この株とかね 仲間を取ってお金出してお金出してとかね
で みんなのお金で全部資金を作って
ずいぶん気楽に仕事をするんですね
それでテイクだけしか考えてないでしょ
まあ年も経たないうちに倒産するんです
だからお金を上げた人々にも
もう元はもう何も戻らなくなっちゃう
そういうひどいことっていうのは結構起きるんです
だから真面目な仕事をする人にとっても
銀行はまあローンをあげないでしょうに
この中小企業とかね 全部ローンでやってますけどね
ローンでやって 仕事をして
それでまたローン払って
また取ってとかね だからそういう世界で金がどんどん回らなくちゃいけないのに
誰かが変なことをしちゃうと
まあそのサイクルもストップするんですね
だから人間というのは面白くて
まあまあ 投資という言葉があるんだけど
できるだけ投資をもう下げて利益だけ上げたいんですね
で 株をね まあ円の株を買って
これ円になるまで期待するんですね
一日でボロ儲けやと で
持ってるものなくなっちゃうんで
それで そういうわけで
このテイクアンドギブという順番にしていますね
それは法則違反なので
ギブアンドテイクにしなくてはならない
難しいことじゃない テイクアンドギブはもう法則違反です
テイク時点でもう奪っているんです
後で挙げたってもかっこ悪いんです
奪ってから じゃあ弁償しますと
シャレになりません だから法則はギブアンドテイク
与えては得ると そこで与えたら得ようとしなくても得られます
与えられても自分のものにはならない
次のステップ はい それで話終わり
幸福になる話は 俗世間の
普通の富豪家になる道っていうのは随分簡単です
それも話終わりました
与えられるようにしてあげてくださいと
皆様に覚えられ 覚えやすい言葉で言えば
あのイルカやらサチやら犬猫に我々出す態度でやってくださいと
人間にしても 随分楽ですよと
これは言葉きついだけど
本当は一番 例えば子供が宿題やりたくないとか何とか言うと
やりなさい あれではなくて
宿題やらざるを得ないようなちょこちょこっと雰囲気作っちゃうと
それ気分をちょっと変えると
なんのことなくやりますから
そうすると すごいお母さん上手でしょうに
で なんとかその気にさせる
そうするとそれが正しいやり方なんです
勉強したくないと言っても
しなさいではなくて 勉強する気にさせる
会社でも社員の人とか
ほとんど能力がなくて
仕事をする気はない この人いくら言っても理解していないとかね
この管理者が文句を言ったってもね
それはもう管理者がその気にさせればいいんじゃないんですかね
喜んで仕事をしたくなる
だから そのわずかなシンプルな法則で
世間世界の問題は解決します
今日の今のポイントは
与えられても この悪事を働かせて金持ちにならないで
ちゃんと正しく 合法的に豊かになっても
与えられたものは自分のものにならないんです
生まれてから幸福になる道具を探し求めるんです
我々は生まれるとか何も持ってないんです
それから道具を探しているんです
幸福で生まれることはあり得ません
誰も幸福を背負って生まれるということは
これは成り立たないんです
誰でも赤ちゃんだから
これからなんです 幸福か不幸かということは
幸福の道具は持って生まれるのではないので
与えられたものであっても
最終的には自分のものにはなりません
だから与えられたものだから
本来自分のものにならないんです
だからそこはすごい大事なポイントなんですが
幸福はレンタルなのです
執着してはいけないということなんです
だから 次のフレーズで覚えておきましょう
夫も妻も子供などもレンタルなんです
自分のものになりません
なった人がいるならば手を挙げてください
だから現実的にはもう史上もうなったことないでしょうね
だからなんでそれ言って悪いんですかね
それがわかった方がいいでしょうね
レンタルやと 赤ちゃんが生まれたら
あ レンタルやと 自分のものになりません
レンタルだったら子育てる
楽しみを楽しめばいいし
一人前にしてあげる楽しみを楽しめばいいし
それからはい さようならと
レンタル時間が終わりましたと
だから金もらっても消えてしまうでしょ
自分でマイホーム作っても
日々古くなって壊れていくでしょ
それでも税金払わなくちゃいけないでしょ
自分が買った土地で自分が作った家なんですけど
もう役所から来て 全部どれぐらい値打ちあるのかと計算して
はい これぐらい払ってくださいと
それ自体でわかるでしょ
自分のものでないということは
でも税金払わなかったらどうなるんですかね
政府は強引に取りますね
だから何一つも自分のものにならない
だから一番わかりやすいでしょうね
夫も妻も子供もレンタルであると覚えておけば
他のことは言うまでもないでしょうに
本当は今日書いてないんだけど
この体もレンタルなんです
体も私のものになりません
レンタルの決まり守って使用しなくてはいけないんです
美味しいんだからってパクパク食べてはいけません
決まりが レンタルの決まりがあります
寝たいんだから これ楽しいんだから 1 日中寝てやるぞと
これはもう決まり破ってます
契約書が それでも自分から逃げていきますね
だから自分が好き勝手に体の維持管理もできない
病気になるとか 勝手に病気になるし
風邪を引くときは勝手に風邪を引くし
年取る場合はどんどんどんどん毎日勝手に年取っていくし
レンタル期間が終わった時点で死んでしまうし
だから本当は夫妻のところじゃなくて
この体さえもレンタルであると
ですから 逃げるものは追わずという
これが理性的な生き方なんです
逃げるものを追っていくと
何の幸福もなくなっちゃうんです
若さ 体力 健康などから
財産 親族などのすべては自分から離れていく法則なんです
すべて財産も権力も地位も知識も家族も
自分の子供も孫も みんな逃げるんです
出ていくんです それは法則です
逃がさないということは法則違反です
非道徳にもなります それで逃がさないとあなたを
これが法則違反です 罪になります
自分の子供は徹底的に自分に過ぎてほしいと思っちゃうと
精神的に病気になりますね
マザコンになったり いろいろ子供たちが一人前で生活できなくなっちゃってて
完璧に親に依存する羽目になっちゃうんです
だから一人の人間をダメにしたんだから
これ相当な罪なんです
あまりも愛着の親がやっちゃいますよ
子供の機嫌取って取って
ずっと私のそばにいてほしいという
それでその子供の人生がもう台無しになるんです
だから一人の人生を台無しにするということは
どれほど罪かと思いますかね
だからはい バイバイさようならという調子で子供育て子育てをする母親が善行為しているんです
全然執着もしないし 勉強してこないんじゃ知らない
お母さんが お母さんにとっては勉強したってもしなくてもどうでもいいんだけどね
苦しむのはあんただよとかってね
どちらかに決めなさいよと
将来乞食になるか 普通の人間になるかと
そんな感じで言うと みんなビシビシ頑張る仕事するんで
子供たちも それで仕事を見つけて独立すると
はい バイバイバイバイと
きれいさっぱり見送ると
みんな幸福なんです それが善行為なんです
ちょっとでもその道が外れると悪行為になります
だから我々はしらしらししてかなり悪行為しています
で 強烈な欲 執着があることで心は汚染しているんです
だから逃げるものを追うと
追うということは この逃げ去るものに対してすごい執着があるんですね
心は汚れていますよ 例えばこのもうお互い仲良くして同棲していて
もうどちらかに嫌になっちゃって
じゃあ別れましょうといったところで
一人がなかなかこれ忘れる
忘れることできなくて
また仲直りしよう また元に戻れと言ったり
ストーカーやったり その人を殺したりもするでしょうに
だから逃げるものは追うんじゃないんです
何も追う必要はないんです
レンタルですから 空いてるもので喜んで
まあ期間が終わったらもう手放すんです
その性格だったら 無執着ということが心に生まれてくるし
心は汚れないんです 好きなもの全ては離れてゆくと理解
納得するんです 本当に幸福になりたければ
すべて離れていくものだと理解して
納得してから仕事するんです
そこを納得してからマイホームを建てるんです
すべて離れていくのだということをわかった上で結婚するんです
全然トラブルは起こりません
はい それから最後 真の幸福
道具のコレクターをやめて
道具を上手に使える能力を得るんです
今まで人間というのは道具のコレクターだけ
迷惑だけなんで 道具はいっぱいあるんだけど
使えないしね なぜ幸福の道具が必要かと
なんで我々はそれでも金が欲しいでしょうに
家が欲しいでしょうに
なんで道具が欲しがるんですかね
なぜ金が必要ですかと問いてみましょう
現代はまあ全部まとめれば金になりますからね
道具っていうことは なんで我々は金が欲しいと思いますか？まあいろいろ答えがあるでしょう
最終的な答えは苦しみがなくなる
楽しくなるなんです 人がなんであなた金が欲しいと言うの？と
旅行したいんだよとかね
そんなことを言ったっても
これ最終的な答えじゃないんで
なんで旅行したくなるの？日本でずっといてもうつまらなくなった
退屈になった 苦しみでしょ
それで旅行したら？旅行したらちょっと気分が変わりますからね
楽しくなるでしょうと
だから結局は最後の答えはそれで終わります
苦しみがなくなること
楽しくなること そのために道具が必要なんです
ですから 幸福とは心で感じるものなんです
もので道具ではありません
で 旅行したい人に金あげても幸福感じるわけじゃないんです
金がないという苦しみがあったならば
その瞬間で金があったっていう入ったという喜びはありますけど
やっぱり旅行して あ 楽しいなと心で感じるんです
心で楽しいなと感じなきゃ幸福じゃないんです
だから心に楽しみを作らせる
起こらせる道具だけなんですよ
だったら道具の収集家に凝りったりなるんじゃなくて
道具使って心の楽しみを作らなくちゃいけないんです
何を 何かを得る前に それで喜びを感じられるのかと調べるんです
あれ欲しい これ欲しいの道をやめましょう
それではなくて あれが欲しいと思ったんだけど
それで私にはどんな楽しみが生まれるのかとチェックしなくちゃいけないんです
ただ欲しいんだからって言って買うんじゃないんです
欲しかったんだから象さん買いましたと
話にならないでしょうに
かっこいいんだからトラも買いましたと
それじゃなくて それでいいのかい？と
それで幸福 楽しみを得られるのかと
だから私も犬か猫か飼いたいんだけど
毎日家にいないんだから
2日  3日  4日とかね しょっちゅう空けてますからね
その間では この命の心配はね
考えちゃうと もう楽しみよりは苦しみが多いんだから
じゃあやめましたと やめているんです
だから あ 買いたい はい
買っちゃった それではダメなんです
買いたかったんだからとかね
で そういう私も時々無駄な買い物をしたり
一回でも使わないものを買ったりはしますけど
その場合ははっきり私は知ってます
これはただ買いたいだけやと
この品物を手に入れたいだけで使わないんだと
で 買って これどういうものか
まあこんなものか 早く置いて
だからそういうバカな買い物をする時でも
この理解があった上でやれば失敗じゃないんです
どうせそういうバカな買い物っていうのは借金ではしませんでしょ？分割払いでもしないでしょ
だから失敗じゃないんです
分割払いで買う場合は
どうしても必要なものでなければダメなんです
はい  2種類の道具 道具 2種類に分けられます
食事 服 住居などの体が壊れていくことを一時的に避ける道具
我々の体が壊れていくんですよ
これ ちょこちょことスピードを遅くしたいんです
必ず壊れて死にます もう死ぬのは 1週間でも死にます
食べないでいると だから毎日食べて
これはもう 80年ぐらい延ばしてもらいます
壊れて死ぬこと で 服も同じでしょうし
住居も同じでしょうし
薬も同じでしょうし この道具は要りませんということはあり得ないんです
体が壊れていく 病気になったところで放っておけば
もうさっさと死んでしまいますね
だから薬を入れて ちょっと寿命を延ばしてもらおうかなと
だから我々は生きるということは
毎日寿命を延ばしているんだ
1 日  1 日  1 日 で だからといって
これ千年とか百年とか伸びませんしね
今日1日頑張ってもせいぜい 2 日間ぐらいは生きていられます
それで明日も頑張ると
もう一日残ってるんだから
三日間生き延びることはそうじゃないんです
明日頑張ると まだせいぜい二日間ぐらいは生き延びられると
一部がチャラになっちゃうんです
大体仏教で大体一食満腹して食べれば一週間生活できるんだと
その栄養で ということは
二日続けて食べると二週間ですかね
ないでしょ？一週間です
しかし その道具は欠かせない
そこは何とかして得なくちゃいけない
それは take だけでやるなよと
奪い取るなよと その必要な道具を与え
与えざるを得ないように
自分の義務のことをするんです
で 音楽 絵画などの心を喜ばせる道具もありますね
ただ楽しいだけで全然役に立ちません
そんなのはなくたっても生きていられます
音楽やらもうね 絵画やら芸術やら映画やらね
舞台劇場やら相撲大会とかね
スポーツ観賞とかなんだらかんだらとかね
そんなことをテレビで見なくたってもね
で 行かなくたってもね
人間は生きていられますよ
でもやっぱり楽しいでしょ
野球試合を見に行ったらクタクタ疲れますけど
同時にどこかで楽しみもあります
で それはこの必ずではないんですね
その道具は まあ余裕があればなんです
その二種類よく覚えてください
これ勘違いそっちだでも
人間勘違いしているんです
どちらでも度を超えては不幸になります
それだけではなくて 度を超えてはならないんです
例えば この病気な人に治療するということは当たり前のことでしょうに
アメリカでは このオバマさんが随分も大変大騒ぎして喋ったのは
このなんとかという健康のなんだらかんだらプログラムでしょ
それは誰にでももう治療を受けられるようにいろいろ改良するんだ
それにアメリカ人が大反対なんですね
いかにイカれているかっていうことなんです
そんなのはもうもう選挙宣伝にもならないでしょうにと
国が豊かということは
どんな人にも病気になったら治療を受けられるということでしょうに
一部の人しか治療を受けられないならば
もう残酷な国でしょうに
しかし そんなことをやると大変や
大変 くだらない金持ちが自分の金ばっかしで
そこで生活したいんですね
あの税金は自分のために使ってくださいと
まず人のために使わないでくださいと
例えばもうGM会社にあげてくださいとか
そういう態度なんです
戦争に使ってくださいと
また 心が汚れないように注意してその道具を使用するんです
道具 2種類 で 適当にどこう来れないというので獲得しましょうよ
それも与えられるように状況を作るんですね
それから だからといって心汚れないようにするんです
ある人の音楽を聴いたらすっごく楽しくなるかもしれませんだけど
頭イカれたら困ります
その人の追っかけ屋さんになっちゃって
仕事も辞めて どこででも演奏会に行くとか
あれは精神的にも病気になっているんですね
家中ポスター貼ったりして
スケジュールを綿密に調べて
もう日本全国走り回ると
そういう病気の人々も結構いるでしょう
楽しかった それは家に帰りましょうということでいいでしょうに
これやみつきになったりとかね
そこでどこへいるんですね
だから道具を使う時でも
こんなものはどうしたっても
まあ壊れていくものであると
離れていくものであると
だからまあ適当にレンタルだから使って
自分の用に使いましょうという程度で使わなくちゃいけない
要するに 金持ちになる前に良い人間になることなんです
わかりやすく言えば 金持ちになろう
知識人になろうと思った時点で
得ることを先に考えているんですね
もう法則壊してるんです
だから不幸になるのは決まってるんで
もう犯罪者だから 何より先にも人間になりましょうと
良い人間になりましょうという
そこが誰でも学ぶべきことなんです
それが道具の使い方なんです
先に道具の使い方を学ぶ
それから適当に道具を見つかる
だから日本であろうが
アメリカでヨーロッパで欠けているのはそのところなんですね
学校では教育はやってますけど
人格を作る教えは 0 それがごまかすために道徳の授業があるんで
あんなのは取り消した方がいいんです
何の意味もないんです
すべてに関わってないと
どんな授業であっても
それがどう使うのかと
どのように人に役に立つのかというところがずっと一貫していないと
数学の授業でも 地理学の授業でも
科学の授業でも どこでも同じことなんです
では 歴史を学んで役に立たんでしょうに
役に立つようにしなくちゃいけないんです
かつてはこういう こういうことでしたから
じゃあ我々もだったらどのようにすればよろしいでしょうかと
歴史のある出来事を子供たちに丸暗記しなさいというではないでしょうに
そればっかりでしょ 日本史を丸暗記させて
そこを試験でどこまで丸暗記したのかと調べるだけで
それでは人間は出来上がりませんね
だから 歴史の授業で何かの歴史の出来事を教えたならば
これから我々は何を学ぶんでしょうかねとかね
それが必要なんです それは欠けているんです
それがいい人間になる道なんです
次の心の汚れと幸福の幸福感
心の汚れが不幸を悩み
苦しみを感じさせます
心に汚れがある 例えば嫉妬がある
憎しみがある 恨みがあると幸福は感じないでしょう
あるいはあまりにも欲に陥る
あるいは恋に陥る もう苦しみなんです
だから心が汚れるともう不幸を感じるんです
悩み 苦しみを感じるんです
豊かであっても 心が汚れていると不幸を感じません
世間的に豊かであっても
心が汚れていると感じませんよ
もう一度思い出してください
ジャクリーンオナシスの億万長者のところじゃないんですよ
金持ちは その人々は それでも人生
全然幸福を感じたことない
精神的に問題の人になるところまで苦しんじゃったんです
というのは 本人の心が汚れていたんです
だから心が汚れると 豊かな人であってももう鈍足不幸なんです
これがすごく気をつけましょうよ
金があるかないかじゃないんです
幸福の秘訣は 心が汚れているか否かなんです
億単位でお金が回ってくるんだからといって
幸福を感じるわけじゃないんです
本当に不幸になりたいと思うならば
物に依存する前に心を清らかにすることを優先するんです
本当に 不幸 え？不幸って言ったっちゃって
すいません 本当に幸福になりたいと思うならば
訂正します で まことに幸福になりたいと思うならば
物に先することはちょっと気をつけた方がいいんです
ちょっとのところじゃないんです
これも気をつけて それより先に心の心が汚れないことが優先なんです
道具は使っても 心は汚れないことにする
楽しい音楽を聴いても楽しくなるんだけど
汚れないようにするというところがポイントです
そうするといつでも楽しく生きていられます
人の本業は心を清らかにすることです
私の本職は 何となくみんな困ってますけどね
困る必要ないんです 誰でも幸福になりたいでしょ
だったら心を清らかにすることは何よりも先決で
それが優先で それが本職なんです
それが一人一人人間の本業なんです
もう一つポイントがあります
幸福になる 見方を変えられる
これ微妙なずるがしこいポイントですけどね
執着でやみくもに財産を奪いまくるのではなく
見方を変えてみるんです
とにかくもう奪いまくりましょうと金を取りまくる
もうボロ儲けしようではなくて
見方を変える 豊かになって
人に優しい人々を助ける人間になるかなとかね
私はもう金儲けでいっぱい
こういうこういうことをするそうとかね
時々いますね 子供 若い時も学校で何としてでも医者になりますよとか思う人々いるでしょう
なぜかというと 自分の身の回りでいろいろ人が病気になって
もうどうすることもできなくて
医者もなくて困ったところで経験した人は
やっぱり何としてでも医者になりたいと思う場合は大体なりますよ
その場合は試験も合格します
金もうけたいって気持ちは全くないんです
医者になって人を助けたいと
医者になって身を張ってやろうと思う人々は
結構落第するんです そうやってちょっと見方変える
結婚することでわがまま奔放をやめてみる
なんで結婚するのかで
わし今まですごいわがままで行ったからね
これからこれやめたいんだと
人のことも考えて気になって
自分のわがまま奔放も抑えて生活してみたいんだよと
他人のことも心配する人間になろうかなとか
思考を変える そんな目的で全然誰も結婚しないでしょ
だからみんな失敗するんです
結婚するのは一人で収入を得て一人で喜んでいるのは
これはわがままありすぎ
もう一人に分けてあげると
一緒に生活してみると
分けたらそれで終わりですから
一緒に生活すると終わらないんですね
財産分けるだけじゃなくて
相手の気分も取らなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうし
相手の希望通りに自分の人生変えなくちゃいけないし
もう最悪ですけど まあそこを期待して
それで自分のエゴをなんとか制御しますよと
じゃあ自分のエゴ制御するために結婚すると問題起こると思いますか？喧嘩になると思う？夫婦喧嘩なんかにはならないでしょうに
そうすると万々歳幸福でしょ
何年も一緒にいたんだけど
一回も喧嘩したことがないんだと
そういう理想的な夫婦が仏典で記録しているんです
ナクラマーターナクラピタという
またお釈迦様のものすごく仲良しなんです
で なんでマーターピタ母と父で入れているかというと
お釈迦様が自分の息子だと思っているんです
で いきなりあ これうちの息子やとせがれやと言ったりして
みんなびっくりしちゃって
お釈迦様は反対しなかったんです
それで仏教ではもうそのままもう名前が通ってしまったんです
これ ボロボロ年でね お釈迦様に会って言うんでしょうね
私 まあ男がね 言うんですよ
私は この女の人はまあ娘の時
いわゆるインドは早いんだからね
14  15  6歳の時結婚するんでしょうね
で お嫁にもらいましたけど
その日から一回だけでも私に気に入らないこと
気に障る言葉とか言ったことはない
やったことはないんだと
で 奥さんも同じこと言うんですね
私は何も知らない ただの金持ちの娘でお嫁に行ったんですけど
この人はその日から私のこととても大事に守ってくれて
ひった言葉も厳しいことは言ったこと言われたことはないんだと
だからすごい それは理想的な夫婦関係をそのエピソードで入ってるんです
私たちは大失敗でしょ
新婚旅行に行って 帰る時ももう 2
3回喧嘩しているんです
だからそれが道具揃うだけの人生で
それで幸福になる保証はないんです
だから結婚する女性も
これからもうわがままではなくて
人のために生きてみましょうと
子供ができたら子供のために
女性だから子供を産まなくちゃあかんやと
これは我々のもう大変な責任であると
だから子供を産みますよと
産んで育てますよと それで私は立派な人間になりますと
自我がなくなって わがままなくなって
その目的で結婚するべきなんです
男も男で 一人で勝手で生活するんじゃないやと
他の何人かのために必死で頑張らなくちゃいけないんだと
朝から晩まで自分が遊ぶために金儲けているんじゃないんだと
この人々を幸せにするためや
それで結婚生活はわがままをなくす目的に入れ替えるんです
この思考ちょっと変えるだけで
結果が断然的に違うんです
知識 権力などが得るたびに謙虚になるとかね
なんであんたそんなに知識を追っているのかと
やっぱり知識を得て さらに謙虚にならなくちゃいけないんだと
よ なんとか言い訳を作ってください
思考を変えてみてください
それで立派な幸福になります
見方を変えることで 完璧ではないが
危険が減りますね このやり方で完璧に幸福になるということは
ちょっと言いづらいんですね
しかし ちょっとするがすくやり方なんです
するがすくやっちゃうと結果がないんだだから真面目にやらなくちゃいけないんですけど
真面目に実行してみると
結構危険がない 幸福な人生は成り立ちます
悩み苦しみない 危険のない人生だ
はい 次 限りのない幸福という
自分も他人も幸福になる道
それは仏道ですね 心の喜びと安穏
心の気持ちは他人にも移るんです
喜びを感じる優しい心で生活すると
その波動は周りにも移るんです
だって人がご飯食べると私たちは美味しいとは思わないんだけど
すごく喜んで食べてるって
その喜びが感じられますね
一切の生命が幸福でありますようにというモットーで生きる人は
世間を味方に変えるんです
だから この心の波動が伝わるというね
ことで 自分が幸福の波動を作っちゃえば
これが周りにも移ってしまいます
ですから  この心の喜びを感じなくちゃいけないんです
必ずも心で喜びを感じないと
楽しくいないと それが皆の楽しみに
幸福にもなるんです それだけの話です
すべての生命が幸福でありますようにということは
自分のモットーにする
これでこのこの問題解決するんです
誰でも幸福になります
これが物理的な豊かになる話だったら成り立ちません
物に幸福がないんです
心に幸福があるんです
これはまんべんなく際限なく広げることはできます
勘違い直します 財産などの道具は幸福だと勘違いすると
勝者も敗者も最後に不幸になります
これは説明しましたからね
道具こそが幸福やと思っちゃうと
どちらでももう落ちてしまいます
心の喜びが幸福だとすると
その幸福は貧富の関係がなく
誰にでも達することができます
金があるかない マイホームあるかないか問題ではありません
心の幸福であると言うならば
誰にでもその幸福を感じられる権利が出てくるんです
だからゼロ和の法則は消えます
もうないんです 全くもないんです
仏教では どんどん増えていくんです
で 我は他より偉いと思う
邪道をやめて 皆平等である仲間であるということにする
それも勘違い直すことなんです
みんな我は偉いと思っているんだから
相当の勘違い そこを直してみな平等であって
生命は仲間であると入れ替えるんです
強引にでも入れ替えなくちゃいけないんです
この世にこの勘違いを直してほしいんです
幸福は道義にあらす 心の問題であると
心の喜びであると そこを直しておく
で 一切の生命が幸福でありますようにということはモットーにする
そうすると敵が消えてしまう
みんな味方に直るんです
で  3番目 我は偉いという邪道をやめて
これ邪道で罪なんです
平等だと みんな仲間だと
で 笑顔を消すんです 仏道っていうのはそういうことなんです
ものを得るたびに依存症が強くなる
不安 不満 苦しみが増える
もの道具ですから 得るたびにそういうことになります
心は一方的に汚れる道に入る
だから 俗世間の幸福論というのは一方的に心を汚れていく道なんです
ものが幸福が幸福を与えてくれるんだと思っているんだから
それで物に依存するでしょ
執着するでしょ 心がもう汚れてるんです
そこを理解することが仏教なんです
ものに道具に依存することが少なくなるほど
心が自由になるんです
だから できるだけ依存することを少なくしましょうと
一人の女性と結婚してここまで幸福なら
三人とも結婚するそうとかね
冗談じゃないんです イスラム教以外はできませんだけど
清らかになる 幸福感が増すます
で ものに依存しないことになれば
もういきなりできませんよ
だから余計なものやらね
ついてるものは徐々に徐々に徐々に依存しないことになってくると
どんどん楽になっていくんです
そこを覚えておきます
ですから ものに依存しないで
幸福を充実感を経験できるように
心を強化することに 浄化することに励むのです
あのものに依存しないと言ったっても
弱い者一人できません
ものに依存しませんと思ったら
心が強くないとできません
心が弱いお母さんに子供を一人生活させることはできないんです
自分が寂しくなるんです
心弱い 心弱いお母さんがいつまでもあんたもう家にいるつもりですか？と独立しなさいと言うんです
だから 一つだけでも品物を離す
離れるから離れることに強さが必要なんです
だから我々は心の強さを作らなくちゃいけない
それから汚れ浄化させなくちゃいけない
心を そういうのはもう避けられない
もうもうもう決まりです
世界 真理としては すべてを捨てて出家して
釈尊が解脱によって究極の幸福に達したんです
だからお釈迦様を実例出しちゃったんです
一切捨てたんです ただ
衣一枚で出家したんです
何も持ってない 私たちに想像できる捨て方じゃないんです
王位を捨てるんですから
王位を捨ても王子でいればいいでしょ
いえ それも捨てる それだったら家族と一緒にどこかで生活すればいいでしょ
農業でもやって いえ それも捨てると
だったら家からいくらお金持ってけばいいでしょ
いえ それも捨てると 全部捨てるんです
堂々とホームレスの生活になるんです
なって見せたんです 究極の幸福に達せられますよと
しかし すべて捨てて出家したんだけど
悟りませんよ 時々日本でいますからね
頭剃ったらすべてOKだと思っている人もいますけどね
もう髪の毛がなくなっただけ
で 出家しても悟りませんよ
心を浄化しなくちゃいけないんです
お釈迦様 出家したら悟るならば
インドにいた人々はみんな悟っているでしょうに
他の宗教の人々も出家でしたからね
でもそれから心浄化するんです
それで究極な幸福に達するんです
一切の物事に執着をしない
依存しないという境地に達することが解脱なんです
やがてこの体にも執着しない
という境地に達するんです
心が浄化することによって
浄化することによって
いらない いらない いらない
いらない いらないと 自分の体にも
もう全部五蘊にも執着しないという気分になったら
もうそれが解脱なんです
それが悟るという境地なんだ
これは究極の幸福の境地なんです
一人が解脱すると 一人が地獄に落ちるということはあり得ませんね
人の功徳を全部奪い取って
自分が悟って もうあの人は地獄の人だと
それはあり得ませんですからね
一人でも解脱すると 周りは幸福になるんです
逆なんです 一人でも真理に達した人がいれば
その周り 仲間 大勢の人々がいくらかでも清らかになって幸福になります
ブッダが悟ったことで
もう 2100 年間もずっと人々は幸福の道を歩んでいるんです
ですから 敗者がないんです
仏教では これ最後だと思います
仏道は得る道ではなく
捨てる道です 得るとは誰かから取ることです
捨てることで他人が不幸になりませんし
皆にも捨てることができます
私が私が持っているものは放棄しましたと
誰かさんが不幸になったと
ありえないでしょう それから誰にでも自分持っているものを捨てることできるでしょうに
捨てることで幸福になるというならば
誰も不幸にならないで幸福になります
得ることは幸福やというと
得た途端誰かが品物なくなってるんですね
だから仏道は捨てるということで一貫して説かれてます
それで捨てるの定義 捨てるという意味は執着をなくすことです
このボーンと物を捨てることじゃないんです
物を捨てても欲しかったなという気分があったら捨ててないんです
心の汚れを落とすことです
だから わかりやすい例えで言えば
赤ちゃんを捨てるんじゃなくて
赤ちゃんに対する執着を捨てるんです
赤ちゃんが育ちます しっかりと
しかし 執着 愛着 私のものやってことはない
そういうことです まだありますか
で 富豪にも貧困の人にも出家にも執着を捨てられます
富豪が富豪 その財産捨てなくても
財産に対する執着を捨てられます
貧乏な人も結構執着強いでしょ
執着は捨てられます 出家しても何も持ってないんだから
もう 解脱やとありえません
執着 心にある汚れを捨てられます
執着を捨てるとは 世間と戦うことでも
財産を壊す 自然を破壊することではありませんね
だから世間と戦う必要もないし
財産を奪う必要もないし
自然を破壊する必要もないし
他宗教でよくやってるでしょ
人を殺すことが大変ありがたいことやとか
原子爆弾を作ることはとてもありがたいことであると
神様の教えを守るためには原子爆弾を持たなくちゃいけないとか
とんでもない道なんですよ
執着を捨てればいいんです
仏教はすべての生命に心脳幸福に達する道を説くんです
ですから 一切の生命 だから生きることは競争ですよ
しかし 仏道で説かれているように競争すると
敗者は成り立たない 敗者がいない
真の勝利への道です ということで終わりと思います
はい そういうことで 仏教が語るこの幸福に至る道っていうのは
実践しやすく また簡単で
ややこしいものは何もなく
シンプル また論理的で
すぐ結果が得られる ほんのちょっとの調整で
すべてグッとに逆にこう
幸福の方向に好転する方向に変わるんです
それで終わるじゃ終わるんじゃなくて
究極的な心の安らぎ 解脱まで得られる同じ一本の道なんです
だからこの世の幸福 悟らなかったら死後の幸福
それから悟りという究極の幸福を一貫して並べている教えですね
お釈迦様のお釈迦様の教えはね
いろいろ開祖様の教えは違いますけど
そういうことで結論付けて話を終了します
どうもありがとうございます
ご質問ある方 遠慮なく挙手してください
皆さんも全然質問ないぐらいよく理解されてるということですか
そういうことにするしかないね
素晴らしい では 奥の方の方ですか
お話どうもありがとうございました
身近な例で恐縮なんですけれども
私のですね 妹が最近赤ちゃんを産みまして
今 3ヶ月の女児がいるんですけれども
最近その産後のですね
ホルモンのバランスの関係なのかで
ちょっと体調を崩してまして
夜眠れなくて 自分の先々の健康の状態が不安であると
子育てに自信が持てないという状況で
ちょっと感情が不安定になっていまして
涙を流したりとか そういう状況で苦しんでいるということなんですけれども
そういった時に仏教の知識とか理解のないそういう家族に対して
何かちょっと気休めというか
気を楽にするような言葉をかけたいと思っているんですが
どのように声をかけたらいいのかというのが迷ってまして
この点て何か教えをいただけたらと思います
はいはい あの この気休めの話はないでしょう
気休めってのはごまかしでしょう
そんな気休めの問題じゃなくて
現実的なもう大変な問題でしょ
そういうのは だからしっかり具体的な対処対策方法を考えなくちゃいけないんです
子供が生まれると もうものすごく体調も崩して
もうどうしようもなくて
もう大体もう大変ですよ
なんでそうなるのかというと
最初からの誤解があるんですね
産んだ母親が育てるべきだと
その人はくったくた産みましたから
もう もうくったくた疲れてるでしょうに
体力はないでしょうに
だからおっぱいあげる程度でお願いして
子供を育てるのは周りみんなの仕事なんです
これは自然法則で 一人が子供を育てるんじゃないんです
だから本当は親戚と一緒に
大家族が人間にとって一番生活しやすい安全な環境なんです
それは現代人が壊しちゃったんだから知ったことではありません
ですから 最低旦那さんでももうものすごくもう
手加えなくちゃいけないんです
それで疲れるのかと なんで疲れるのかというと
あー大変だ もう夜 夜遅く
夜目が覚めると私が睡眠不足で困るでしょとかね
自分のことを考えてるんですね
自我が割り込んでいるんです
結婚したのは 子供を作ったのは
この自我をなくすためなんです
いや 仕事が入ったぞという感じでならなくちゃいけないんです
いや 仕事だよと だから 1時半で子供赤ちゃんがギャーと泣いたら
まあおっぱいをあげる
あげなくてもよろしいんだったら
お父さんがもうちょっと寝かしてあげればよろしいし
その時間お母さんが寝ると
それでおっぱいの時はお母さんがおっぱいをあげたりするとかね
そうやっていつでも共同作業で
これわがままエゴをなくして
この子供を育てなくちゃというね
これすごい大事な仕事やと
それにはもうそんなに疲れたとか言っていられる場合じゃないという感じに作らないと
それを作ったらエネルギーは出ていきます
何の苦ともなくなっちゃうんです
すごくエネルギーが出ていきます
こんなの話にならんやと
赤ちゃんは泣くんだよと
そっちおっぱいあげなくちゃいけないんだよと
だから特に産んだお母さんの精神的な不安とかね
体力減退とかね そういうとことっても労わってあげなくちゃいけないんです
あるいはお母さんがあまりにも体が弱くて
もう夜は起きられませんよとおっぱいはあげられませんよと言ったら
現代時代ではね よくわかりました
あんた夜寝て寝てくださいと
夜 1回分のミルクはもう哺乳瓶であげましょうと
おっぱいでもね まあできない
出る人にとってはできないわけじゃないし
あるいはそうでなければいろいろフォーミュラありますからね
それは夜 1回 2回ぐらいでもね
それで育てる人々はいくらかお互い協力し合って育てますよ
子供っていうのはみんなの責任なんです
夫婦だけの責任じゃないんです
親戚の責任でもあって
周りの責任でもあって
全体的には国全体 みんなの責任なんです
だから我々は困っている子供が見た
見た次第で助けてあげなくちゃいけない
その子は誰ものであっても構いません
子供が遊んでると ちょっと危険なことをしようとするならば
誰の子供であっても そこはすぐ守ってあげなくちゃいけない
これは大人の義務なんです
山口から私は飛行機で来ましたけど
隣のお母さん 若おかあさんが赤ちゃんを抱っこしていたんですけど
でお母さんがじーっと黙っているんですね
これはちょっとまずいんですけどね
子供には何もわからなくても
お母さんというのはペラペラペラペラペラペラわけのわからないことをしゃべらなくちゃいけないんです
子供と わかってわからないとどうでもいいんです
で これでなくそうとね
空気圧変わったりすると
子供はわからないでしょう
耳が痛くなるし いろいろ
ひどい目に遭っちゃうんですね
また小さなところで窮屈でね
まあでも大変です この赤ちゃんにとっては
やっぱりその瞬間で これで私は楽に本を読んで疲れていましたしね
まあもう楽々にずっと降りるところまで本を読もうと機会
計画はあったんだけど
やっぱりそこをやめて
あっ これ自分の仕事やとちょこちょこちょこちょことこの赤ちゃんと遊んだり
で 泣いてるんだけど 私はもうなんでしょうかねと言った途端
もう子供は泣かないんですね
ニコッと笑うんですね
だからいろいろ見ると
これってすごく面白いよとかね
私は変なもういい加減なことを言っているのに
実際のお母さんが言わないんですね
そこでもうこれも引っ張りたくなったんですね
お母さんがもうあれ 私は何のことなく
さっさとこれも引っ張れるところ出して
こう早いとそうと だから私は出家でしょうし
全然知らない人ですし
名前も知らないし しかし赤ちゃんっていうのは人類の財産であって
大人たるものは誰でもその人その人を助けてあげなくちゃいけないんです
そこであの機内で仕事をしている女性の方々も来て
いろいろ何か飲み物であげましょうとかね
だから私も何か飲ませた方がいいやと思わ
喉が喉がすごく乾くんだって
ここにいる時はとかね
言いましたけど まあちょこちょことその女の人が喋っていたんですね
その時だけ子供はずっと顔を笑いながら聞いているんです
だから私はすぐその子供の性格が分かったんですね
その子は自分に何も喋れないくせに
人と喋りたいんですね
喋るのはばっかりなんですけど
だから大人が勝手に一方的にいろいろ喋ればいいんです
私もね 窓からね 泣くんじゃなくてね
空でも見たらどうですかねとかね
これ結構面白いよとかね
大人にしか理解できないことを言うんだけど
子供はジーっと聞いてるんです
そこでフライトアテンダントの女性が来て喋ると
もうこのお姉ちゃんの方がじーっと見ているんです
私はこの人に言ったんです
この子はね もう喋りたいんだから喋ってあげてくださいと
すると結構時間延ばして喋っていたんですね
もう最後の 30 分ぐらいでね
まあ席を替えましたけど
なんか子供を中に何とか連れてきて
何か飲ませようとしたんだから
で で いたらフライトの人がね
そちらちょっと面倒くさいだからね
本当にいろいろ立ってもらったり
座ってもらったりして申し訳ないんだからということで
まあ空いてる席がありますからと
別に移動していただきましたけど
別にあと 30 分だからね
まあどうったことはないし
で それでじゃあまあ最後の 30 分でも本を読もうかなと思っちゃうと
15 分になってくるともう着陸しますから
電気全部消してくださいと言うんだからね
まあそれでまた ですから
その例を出したのは 誰の子供であっても
大人ならそれ一人一人に責任なんですよ
これが子供たちはよくやってますよ
子供同士で年下の子供はよく面倒見るんだから
同じ学年の連中を一緒にしているんだから
すごくもう乱暴 悪にになるんですね
例えば 5 年生と 1 年生を一緒にしちゃうと
5 年生たちがもう先輩だからね
結構面倒見るんです これまた上手なんです
どういうわけかわからないんだけど
ですから 我々はやっぱり子育てってのは一人の仕事をとんでもないんです
例えば 一人のお母さんたちは
時々道連れにして死んだりするんですね
そんなのはあってはならないんです
お母さん 死にたければはい
どうぞと しかし 子供を残しておけと
あなたのものじゃないんだという社会にならなくちゃいけないんです
だから自分で子供を育てられない
だから一人の親の場合は
よく男ならなんとか頑張りますけど
女性の場合は時々もうもう詰まつく人もいますしね
これでしょうがないんですよね
詰まついたところで 私には無理ですから
誰かこの子供を見てくださいと
言うと はい よくわかりましたとかね
飛んでもらうというよね
社会でなければかわいそうでしょうね
もう子供はしょうがないし
その代わりにもうみるみるうちに死んでしまうし
そういうわけで これは気休めではなくて
本格的な問題なんです
答えは子育てではみんなの仕事
関係ある人々にとってはもう話にならない
ちゃんと責任を持って
それぞれ自分の分というか
自分の仕事分を果たさなくちゃいけないんです
おむつ替えることはお母さんの仕事じゃない
それはお父さんの仕事でもあります
電車で見られる 時々ね
若い男たちがね 赤ちゃんを自分で抱っこして
ずっと日曜日だからね
じゃあ日曜日は 1 日中私が面倒見るんだよと
お母さんが楽々にもうみんな家族一緒に旅に出る
赤ちゃんも連れて遊びに行ったって遊びないでしょ？もうお母さんに全部仕事を任せちゃうと
だから今の若い夫婦を見ると結構やってますよ
もうせっかくの日曜日だから
若いしね 遊びに行きたいし
赤ちゃんも抱っこして行くんです
赤ちゃんの道具も全部持って行くんだけど
もう赤ちゃんの道具はベビーカー車に乗せているんだから
それは別に重くないし
赤ちゃんはお父さんがちゃんと抱っこしてるし
泣いたりとお父さんが泣く泣いてあげたりはするし
お母さんが楽々で そうするとお母さんがもういくらか気楽で楽しく遊べるでしょうに
そうするとまた月曜日から自分が自分なりに頑張るんですね
そういうことを覚えておくこと
次のポイントは まあこれこそ私たちの仕事になるんですね
自分のわがまま 私が疲れる
私は寝なくちゃとかね
これをなくすためのもう絶対的なチャンスでしょうに
例えばもう子供がなんか落ちそうになって怪我しそう
いえ 私はちょっとやばいんだから放っておくぞとかね
そんなのはないでしょうに
例えば子供がもう水遊びしたりして
この泥の中に 川の中に滑ってしまったと
私はそうつけているんだからね
これ汚したくない 知らない
そんなこと人間やる？たとえ結婚式に行く予定であっても
子供を助けなくちゃあかんでしょうに
泥の中に飛び込んで だから子供が生まれたっていうことは
私たちにはもう絶対的な
大事な仕事を 宿題が来たことで
それはビシビシとやるしかないんです
その気持ちになると いくらでも力が出てきます
負けませんよと で 今思い出したんですけど
まあ自分が外国でいた時はね
ある教授が一つの授業が終わって
自分の部屋に戻って 眠くて眠くてうとうとしているんですね
そこで私ともう一人の教授が何か話があって
その人の部屋に入ったら
まあなんか我々に見せる顔もないんですね
で まあ大学の話だからね
結構ややこしいことをしゃべったりもするし
で その人何のことなく
実はまだまだ子供が小さいんだから
夜徹夜して子供の面倒見ましたと
だから結構眠いんだと
それ聞いた途端 私もなんかすごく楽しくなったんです
これはえらいことを教えている大学の教授であっても
自分の責任はちゃんとやっていて
明日授業ありますから
もう知りませんよとお前子供の面倒見なさい
それはもうできません
どうせ二人とも知識人だから
そんなこと言っちゃうと大変なことになりますからね
だからもう奥さんの方が疲れてるんだから
もう旦那さんが明日大学の授業あるにも関わらず
もう子供面倒見たんですね
泣くたびに起きて また寝かせてあげて
また起きてまた寝かってあげてとかね
それでちょこちょこ睡眠不足で
でも ああそうですかね
結構可愛いでしょうねとかね
その話もそうなんです
それで疲れがなくなっちゃうんですね
結構可愛いでしょうねとかね
やっぱり赤ちゃんってそんなもんだなとかね
そういう一言葉でも 女性はそれですごい楽になるでしょ
男は大体そんなもんなんです
この悩みを言い合うことで結構リラックスするんです
そういうことだから そんなに大げさな問題ではないんですよ
これ我々のまあ宿命であると
だからこの私もやっぱりこの出家して
この誰かのわがままを徹底的に見ることも人間に必要だよと
だから出家したらもう師匠たちのみんなの面倒を見るんだけど
これ徹底的に我を見るってことじゃないでしょ
やっぱり出家して失敗したのは
子供がいないことだと
子供がいると もうそちらのわがままを徹底的にやらなくちゃいけないんですね
もう理屈は通りません
それで私は これを人格には補わなくちゃいけないということで
結構小さな子供たちを強引にでも拾って
今親いるんだけど もう仲良しになって面倒見るんです
まあ 1 日過ぎるともう結構わがままなんですよ
物は壊すわ 言うことを聞かないわ
もうあれ欲しいって言っちゃうと欲しいだけで
もうちょっと待って 明日
明日ではダメなんですね
そこで私は なるほど この時はすごく落ち着いて
いかにこの子を納得させるのかっていうことは
まあ親がやる仕事でしょう
じゃあ私もやらなくちゃとかね
私も私のそばに子供たちに寝てもらっちゃうと
私は夜寝ないんです 寝るんだけど
そっちを起きるんです
落ちてちゃんと寝ているのかとかね
もう寒くなってるのかとかね
何かかけてあげますけど
15 分でどこに行ったかわからない
それで私は起きて それまた拾ってきて
またちゃんとかけてあげて
それからもう体ぐにゃぐにゃするんだから
いびきかいたりする これでまた体を伸ばして
枕をちゃんと作ってあげて
本人全然知らない 私は結構朝まで仕事するんです
別になんのことなく まあ家に帰れば簡単な話ですけど
せっかく泊まってもらわなくても
やっぱりそれで私たちはやっぱり何か人間として丸めているんです
それが大事なことなんです
だから 親にとってはこれももうもう何のことなくついてますからね
すごくいいことですよ
性格を育てるために はい
もうしゃべりすぎになりましたから
ありがとうございました
ちょうど時間になりましたが
あと一人ほど もしご質問あればお時間ありますけど
いかがでしょうか はい
では最後の一人お願いします
時間ないのですみません
さっき先生のお話の中にまで出てきたんですけど
私 なんというか いわゆる追っかけみたいなことを今までしてきたところがあって
スポーツの試合とかを見に行かせて
で 私は年取っちゃってなかなか聞き取れないという
ちょっと明確に  スポーツの選手とかが好きで
いわゆる追っかけみたいなことをしてきたところがあるんですけれども
今日も試合があったんですけれども
ちょっと抑えようかなっていう気持ちがして
こちらに来たなんですけれども
ちょうどいいお話が聞けたなというところではあるんですけれども
明日も試合があるんですね
それで別に見ることをやることはないなとは思うんですけれども
行くことでまた執着が生まれるっていうことはあると思うんですね
で 今回はちょっとこちらの講演があったので
こちらを選ぶっていうことができたんですけれども
そういう選択がない時とかもあるし
例えばまた私はこれで先生の追っかけになってしまう可能性もあると思うんですよね
それは一緒なんだと思うんですけれども
なので その多分根本的に何か直さなきゃいけないんだろうなとは思うんですけれども
そういう時の気持ちのコントロール方法についてお話があればよろしくお願いします
度を越えないだけの話ですね
だからまあ 他のことに邪魔にならない
妨げにならない 損しない
何も他のこともたくさんやるでしょうにね
我々は人生 1本だけでは成り立ちませんからね
試合だけ成り立ちませんしね
ですから いろんなことをやらなくちゃいけないんですよね
そういうものの邪魔にならない時間というふうに考えた方がね
だから全面的に失敗しないということなんです
人生は 遊んでもいいんだけど
全面的には失敗しないと
全面的にうまくまとめているんだというふうに思い
覚えておけば 自動的に管理になると思います
だから 行くべきですかね
これ行かなかったら大変ですかねとかね
やっぱり今日やること何もないんだからね
じゃあ行きましょうというふうはいいんですよ
に これもやめて あれもやめてね
後回しにして行くんだっていうことはね
まあそれはまあ 例えばもうまあ十年一回も日本に来ないだろうという誰かさんが来て
まあそこはまあだったら一年前から契約予約して
まあ他の用事があっても
それはなんとかなんとかして空いていて行くのはそれは論理的ですけど
やっぱりそれでもね 一年前から予約してあっても
自分の誰かが病気になったりとかね
自分が病気になったりするともう取り消しでしょ
そういう人生だから あの全面的に人生は何一つも損しないように気をつけるという生き方でよろしいと思います
何か損して楽しめれば
あんまり意味がないんですね
うまくいってるんだと
何でもかんでも いう程度にすると
だいたい適度に止まります
そういうふうに頑張ってみてください
はい  ありがとうございました
それでは最後に回向の文を拝読をいたしまして終了したいと思います
合掌してください 回向の文
仏法僧の三宝に礼拝敬し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱が得られますように
サッビーティヨーヨジャントゥ
サッバローボーウィナッサトーマーテーバワットワンテラーヨー スキーディーガーユコーバヴァー バウォトゥサッバマンガ
ラン ラッカントゥサッバデーヴァター サッバプンダヌバーヴェーナ サッバダンマーヌバーヴェーナ サッバサンガーヌバーヴェー
ナ サダー スッティバワントゥテー アビワダナシーリスサ ニッチャンワッダーパチャイノー チャッターローダンマーワッダンティーヤーウィワンノー
スカンバラン
サード サード サード  では
どうもありがとうございます